now are you ready for new Dixie yes yes
is the answer it's been 14 years since
the Dixie Chicks released their album
taken the long way that fought back
against the backlash they received for
bashing George W Bush now the Adhan
swept the Grammys in 2007 but they
haven't made any new music together
since then yes it's so long you know
they've been touring today together for
years but today they finally released
the first single of an upcoming album
this is - lighter nice
[Music]
I like it I don't like how much longer
is this show I can go listen to the
right yeah I know probably one of the
best songs of the year we heard like
little snippets of it and the weeks
leading up this but like that's exactly
want to hear from fiction chicks it's
like a feminist anthem but not like too
overtly in your face it's got that add
to that we always want from the Dixie
Chicks and still they're walking that
line it's like it's so hard to describe
their music like it is country but it's
very rock and that's what taking a long
way that album was was very walking that
line like you don't necessarily find
what that style is yeah it's very rock
consciousness an attitude as well
they've you know you when they you've
won it back when they did Earl right you
know that was a difference like nobody
was doing that in country at that time
right like nobody was doing that they
had in years past but then there's a
long time where everything was just nice
for a while and nobody took those real
big chances and then they got and then
they got torched and another back but I
like that track miss Cheryl says yes so
already for the Dixie Chicks I love them
endorses love it yeah Roberts is another
anthem to the mix you have three sisters
I love it and I'm interested to see if
country radio does anything with this
like one more national a couple weeks
ago there's always music playing
everywhere right and a couple times I
heard Dixie Chicks music playing so I
don't know where Nashville is yeah yeah
it's because they completely ignore
taking along we even know it's swept the
Grammys they're not touch that album in
any kind of waste yeah it's gonna be
interesting to see if they embrace us in
a way